Morena prudo has one of the most
dangerous known abilities in Hunter
Hunter with both the potential and
intent to destroy the world it's a bit
complicated with a lot of rules and
strange interactions but that's why this
channel exists so here's why you should
be afraid of Morena Morena prudo is the
illegitimate child of King nasabi
current gluttonous Overlord of the
karkin Empire this makes her the
half-sister of every prince currently
engaged in the succession War however
those half-siblings all came from very
legitimate wombs whereas mirena's
birthing Zone was rather unsanctioned
King NASA well he gets around and this
is not entirely without strategy these
illegitimate children are more than
likely thrown into the world with the
idea of control in mind because they
often go on to become pretty serious
underworld figures like broccoli and
O'Neill who won assabee's illegitimate
half-brothers each of whom are marked
with two razor blade scars which is
interesting because if you wanted to
keep these illegitimate children's
hidden from the world then you probably
wouldn't make them so easy to identify
so they're born for greatness just in a
different sector of society this one
down here where we don't have to look at
Marana however has other plans as she
stated but I like the scar without it I
would have slid closer to death with
this scar I was able to perch on the
razor's Edge in order to destroy this
dung heap of a world I can keep trying
just a little more which is a fancy way
of saying burn it all morena's views of
this world is that it is unjust
unsightly and even disgusting much like
how the [ __ ] in royalty view her and
this often goes unnoticed but Morena
also likes to wear a crown of thorns
very important because Togashi loves his
religious symbolism in this case
referring to the crown of thorns that
Jesus Christ was forced to wear before
and during crucifixion the idea was to
mock him you know the haha yeah you're
the king the the king of [ __ ] or
something like that I honestly don't
know what the ancient crucifixion dudes
said to him I am of course paraphrasing
the Bible there but that was the General
intention however Morena has adopted
this crown of her own volition she has
embraced her role not only as a false
Monarch but as a preacher of a new way
of living and to complement the
religious reference Miranda even has 22
of her own disciples each devoted to her
vision for the future of the world or
lack thereof in any case Morena
converted these disciples and used them
to Stage a coup taking over the Hayley
family but it was only then that her
true power was Unleashed mirena's
heartsu is called contagion the Etude of
Love whereby through her saliva often
exchanged varicus Miranda can infect up
to 22 people for a total of 23 including
herself it's unconfirmed what net
Affinity Miranda falls into but it could
involve a mixture of transmutation and
enhancement as in transmuting the aura
into the contagion saliva with
enhancement properties spawning later it
could also be emitting saliva with
elements of manipulation or it could
just be pure specialist insanity but
once infected these people become
players in an end game led by game
master Miranda although I would say that
knowing Morena this game follows a very
predictable path essentially the more
you kill murder the more you get
rewarded and the more rewards you get
the easier it becomes to kill murder
more people so it's a vicious cycle over
and over and over again until the world
goes boom Miranda's current rules
stipulate the killing a regular person
grants a player one level meanwhile
killing a nen user will give a player a
mighty 10 levels but even much more
better if a player manages to kill a
[ __ ] in Prince then they will be
rewarded with an astonishing 50 levels
what does that mean why is that
important those are just random numbers
internet man well just just calm down
I'm about to explain upon becoming
infected players automatically have
their Aura control unlocked you know
that thing that can either take months
and months of meditation or a very rough
life-threatening initiation to complete
it's all just gifted instantly to these
players and every level gained results
in an aura boost so the higher your
level the more Aura you have access to
and to Die the level 20 or level 21 both
of which have been stated in the past
kind of contradictory But whichever one
it is the player manifests a unique and
inability and for some comparison it
took gone and kilowatt almost the
entirety of Hunter Hunter to accomplish
this however the ultimate goal is
reaching level 100. after which the
player graduates into what is known as a
member zero and is able to infect up to
22 more people to put it pretty bluntly
it's an encult and it follows your very
classical cult pyramid structure sits on
top with 22 of her close devoted
disciples those disciples then gather 22
of their own devotees who then assembled
22 of their own and so on and so forth
until again World goes boom so there's a
lot of fantastic advantages that this
ability provides the main one is
manifesting ahatsu that is a long and
difficult path there are some low-level
men uses in this world that never
generate their own unique ability but
contagion fast tracks the whole process
and guarantees an inability regardless
of any natural factors however one very
big issue with this is that it's
skipping very necessary steps layers
under the effect of contagion don't
currently have the opportunity to learn
let alone master and implement the basic
principles of nen Concepts such as 10
bran and zetsu are the foundation of
Aura control and lacking those leaves
the players extremely vulnerable I mean
if you don't even know a basic 10 then
you'll never be able to wield your aura
at any sort of efficient level because
it'll just all be leaking away because
you don't know how to how to make it
stay that's what 10 does and if you
don't know zetsu you can have a mask
your appearance so you can't really
sneak up on your enemies and now months
even before we get to all of the
compound principles my God the compound
principles as a result it means that
players can be beaten without even
needing to use net abilities or
potentially needing to invoke any Aura
at all as shown when Nobunaga rather
unceremoniously dismissed the weenie
without a single drop of Aura spent it's
just you know stab in the head and
you're done because it's not like you
know any sort of can or code to be able
to use your aura to block it but that
doesn't matter to the players because
they don't know what they're missing
ignorance is bliss and they're mostly
taken in by the sudden manifestation of
relatively mundane superpowers however
they can make up for this lack of
knowledge and experience with the sheer
or a quantity because if the Chimera
antarctal is nothing else it's that a
critical mass of Aura can overwhelm even
the greatest of nen Masters so for
example if a Haley player were to kill
one million people then that could end
up with 1 million Aura boosts placing
them in the realm of a chimera antoineal
guard or perhaps even King marowam
himself when it comes to sheer or
quantity that does make a lot of
assumptions though one is that there
isn't a level cap because there could be
level 100 may very will be the maximum
but look even then a level 100 player
would still end up with vastly greater
Aura reserves than most Pro Hunters we
have a tendency to think of professional
Hunters as these absurdly powerful Godly
beings but that's only because we
generally focus on the amazing one
sitting right at the top but in reality
the hunter Association is flooded with
primarily mediocre hunters and then if
the level system does go beyond 100 then
it could have diminishing returns
granting less of an aura boost each time
like farming the same enemies in a very
early area in a game can't just stick to
one area or type need to keep moving
beyond one other Advantage contagion
does bring is that it allows the
infected group to act as an end swarm
individually they may be inexperienced
and at the moment very underpowered but
if you're up against 20 nen users at
once then even then veterans are going
to find themselves overwhelmed by
unpredictable interactions speaking of
there are quite a few question marks
surrounding contagion and a lot of
unknown interactions for example Morena
is the game master so we should keep in
mind that it's always possible for her
to introduce new rules or change
existing rules we know this just because
that's the basic idea of nen
modification at any time an end user who
really wants to can invest into a new
condition or restriction to add on to
existing abilities a great recent
example of this would be none other than
crawler who gave his Bandit secret a
delightful bookmark accessory we still
don't know what conditions were put on
for that but crawler said that they were
quite painful to achieve so the idea is
that you can always add new features so
long as you're willing to pay a certain
price nen is all about balance for
example Morena wouldn't be able to
change the rules of contagion to
suddenly assign 50 levels if you kill
random instead of one level because that
would ruin the balance currently princes
are allowed to be worth a whopping 50
levels because they're nigh on
impossible to access and even if you did
good luck killing one of them with their
Guardian Spirit Beast defending them
along with all of the nen using
bodyguards alternatively perhaps Morena
could change the value but the reward
would be affected in direct correlation
so if randoms were worth 50 levels then
all that does is make each level's Aura
boost 50 times less so you could end up
with a level 100 player who only has the
aura output of a level 2 player in the
previous system stuff like that another
aspect we should always keep in mind is
that Morena is not just the game master
she is also a game player furthermore
Miranda is currently the highest level
player sitting at a mighty level 45
meaning that she has killed quite a few
people at most she's killed 45 randoms
and at the very least she has killed
four nen users and five randoms what I'm
very curious about is what happens when
Miranda herself reaches level 100 is she
subject to her own rules does she become
a new member zero and is allowed to
infect another 22 people speaking of the
22 some Haley family members have died
and there is also a question as to
whether Miranda can replenish those
numbers is it a flat 22 and no more or
can Mirena always keep a maximum of 22
infected devotees because if it's a
latter then this is an even more serious
problem than I thought and just just to
interrupt me here for a second look I'm
watching me right now just to interrupt
me we do know the answer to that now
Morena can indeed reinfect one so hail
the family members have been lost and
now a big part of her plan is trying to
infect someone close to srider so that
can always be a maximum of 22 members
means that you can't just gradually
Whittle the numbers down and eventually
deal with the issue that way no you
would need to exterminate the entire
problem at once Poor Man's Rose style
you either get everyone at the same time
or Morena just keeps spreading her
saliva and multiplying there's also the
Curiosity of what would happen if
contagion infected an existing net user
right now it's only been applied to
people who previously had no knowledge
let alone control of Aura but for
example if hisoka were to be infected
would this situation be the equivalent
of playing Contagion on new game plus he
roams around killing and killing as you
know he does acquiring Aura boost and
even attaining a very sudden new and
dangerous ability I mean even if it did
function that way I'm sure it's not
quite that simple because this has yet
to be confirmed but I I have a suspicion
but one of the restrictions for this
ability is that the target needs to be
devoted to Morena and even potentially
prove it in some way because otherwise
surely she would have infected everyone
before staging the curve rather than
after staging the crew there's also a
very morbid thought of can Mirena Farm
her own disciples essentially cultivate
and grow them to become rookie nen users
before consuming them to raise her own
level because currently she would only
need to sacrifice six of her followers
to become a level 100. I don't know if
she would ever do that because in her
own Twisted way she does seem to care I
genuinely love her followers but then
again hard belief often calls for hard
sacrifices perhaps even a sacrifice of
Morena herself which may be the most
terrifying Prospect of contagion in the
future should Togashi continue down the
path of morena's Jesus Z themes then I
would not be surprised if she was
sacrificed and became a martyr which
would of course invoke post-mortem net
of everyone on the ship marana's desires
are some of the most profoundly powerful
if she were to die her ability would
almost certainly Linger on and just
become stronger her remaining disciples
May gain stronger Aura boosts or even
become game Masters themselves capable
of setting rules and splintering off
into their own various nenkolts each
with their own unique tenets of
Destruction that's why this war makes me
a little bit nervous at the moment
because currently the idea to deal with
the problem is kill killing Morena but
that could just make things so much
worse another alternative is that the
Haley family could have their own
personal Judas someone who betrays the
others via mess Slaughter and takes all
of the delicious levels is for
themselves because it really wouldn't be
too difficult to kill eight or so
amateur end users with the right ability
or perhaps there are even multiple
judicisms to die sort of following the
path of the Chimera ants they started
out as a relatively weak group working
together but as soon as they gained a
decent amount of individual power a lot
of them split off wanting to pursue
their own personal desires many of which
was to become their own King but this is
a problem with a big problem no matter
which way it goes actually there's so
many problems Marana has Unleashed a nen
cult disease and even though we've
managed to catch it at an earlier stage
than the Chimera ants it's only a matter
of time before it spirals completely out
of control and when that happens I don't
know just how helpful pigeon handcuffs
are going to be to stop it